hey welcome back to New Rockstars it's
me Mt and just who is the mysterious
Sonia fallsworth anyway I mean she is
the head of British secret intelligence
so if she told us everything then she'd
probably have to kill us however I'm
going to dare to ask the question anyway
who could Olivia Coleman's Sonia
fallsworth be in secret Invasion I think
that there are some interesting
possibilities from the mcu's past as
well as the Marvel Comics lore that we
are about to explore together my nerd
baby so buckle up I'm so glad that
secret invasion is finally here and be
sure to tune in to new rockstars every
Wednesday for our secret Invasion
breakdowns and even more secret Invasion
discussion on our newest channel the
break room and don't forget you can also
grab some of our awesome secret Invasion
inspired merch over at nerd riot.shop to
let people know that you yourself are
not a scroll that's right put those
shape-shifting allegations to rest right
now at nerd riot.shop alright gang let's
talk about the mysterious Sonia
fallsworth and who she could possibly be
and with the last name like fallsworth
one cannot help but connect with Sonia
to the only other false worth in the MCU
James Montgomery fallsworth the British
member of the mcu's adaptation of the
Howling Commandos all the way back from
the First Avenger the Halloween
Commandos were of course the elite
Strike Team of diverse soldiers
assembled by Steve Rogers after he saved
their lives from Hydra captivity and
together Captain America and the Howling
Commandos would become the ultimate
headache for Nazis and hydra agents
alike in World War II as one of the
Allied Forces most creatively daring
combat units and fun facts one of those
Commandos Jim Morita would have a
descendant of his appear as Peter
Parker's principal in Spider-Man
homecoming with the actor Kenneth Troy
playing both characters out of all the
Howling Commandos however James
fallsworth is the most notable due to
the fact that his character was never
actually part of the Howling Commandos
in the comics while follsworth did fight
in various battles in a world war in the
comics he mainly fought in the first
world war on behalf of England as the
costume super spy hero Union Jack
predating Steve Rogers as Captain
America he didn't have any superpower
hours at all but was still a massive
threat to the enemies of Britain
nonetheless the main purpose of his
existence was to strike fear in the
hearts of anyone who would dare threaten
the borders that Britain as sworn to
protect and though we never see him
actually become Union Jack in that movie
Marvel Studios did give James fallsworth
a special Union Jack pin on his hat sort
of their way of teasing a potential
future as the crime-fighting Union Jack
down the line now knowing that James
Montgomery fallsworth is firmly
connected to both Great Britain and
Espionage it wouldn't be too much of a
stretch if a descendant like Sonia
followed in his footsteps in her own way
by becoming a spymaster of MI6
protecting England by gathering Intel
and striking from the Shadows without
the unnecessary flashiness of being a
costume wartime patriotic symbol
becoming for England what essentially
Nick Fury was for America Sonia is
secretly being a descendant of Marvel's
Union Jack which serve as an excellent
payoff to that Union Jack seed Marvel
Studios planted all the way back in
2011. it was an Old English spymaster
that started the tradition a clock goes
up on your time in the circus is done I
like to think I still have a few
juggling acts left in me and juggling is
right because I don't think that this is
the end of who Sonia fallsworth could
possibly be in the MCU I think that
there's also a very real possibility
here that Sonia fallsworth secretly hold
the mantle of one of Iron Man's greatest
foes I know Olivia Coleman I didn't
expect her either the sneaky God of
Espionage themselves the spymaster not
actually a God just a normal human being
now we already know that the secret
Invasion show was purposely meant to set
up rhodey's upcoming armor Wars film and
we also know that the armor War story
from the comics typically deals with
Tony Stark's technology being scattered
across the world and falling into the
wrong hands well did you know whose
actions started the armor wars in the
comics the Spy Masters specifically
after the Spy Master uses their Mastery
of sabotage and thievery to steal a
bunch of Tony Stark's Iron Man suit data
for Justin Hammer to sell on the black
market like the douchebag he is but I
love him so much because Sam Rockwell is
amazing listen gang your enjoying of
Marvel's secret Invasion will not be
complete if you do not watch inside
Marvel on new Rockstar's new channel the
break room yes I will miss being on
inside Marvel dearly but all of my
amazing friends will be answering all
the burning questions after each episode
and will stop at nothing to uncover all
the Scrolls of the MCU on the break room
you'll see all the new Rockstar spaces
that you've come to love as well as
friends of the channel new and old and
celebrity gets will be legally obligated
to make appearances like there are some
up there already for real go look for
yourself join us for every episode of
secret Invasion as we pour over all the
evidence to figure out who is and who
isn't a scroll and if you don't want to
miss a single clue subscribe over at
youtube.com breakroom NR being part of
Iron Man's Rogues gallery spymaster has
repeatedly clashed with Tony Stark in
the comics and has tried to break into
Stark's facilities countless times to
steal Tony's futuristic technology
because ever since Steve Jobs died it
hasn't been the same and the title of
spymaster has been pretty fluid over the
years as multiple people have taken up
the mantle of being the Eternal thorn in
Iron Man's side much like Sonya
fallsworth is just another in a long
line of MI6 spy Masters interesting
Sonia fallsworth eventually being
revealed as the mcu's adaptation of the
spymaster would not only be a phenomenal
way to tee you already up who were armor
Wars but it would also line up very well
with the overall thematic tension of the
series because if you really think about
it secret invasion is just one big
battle of the Spy Masters Nick Fury the
world's greatest buy master versus
graphic the scroll spymaster versus
Sonia falsworth the MI6 fightmaster like
I honestly believe Marvel Studios
decision to not include spymaster in the
original Iron Man trilogy was an
incredibly wise choice because of this
in my opinion the MCU spymaster is best
introduced in a proper spy Thriller like
secret Invasion by doing that first you
can establish how badass of an obscure
character they are before setting them
loose on Tony Stark's Legacy and secrets
in the armor Wars movie and with the
legendary Samuel Rockwell being strongly
rumored to return as Justin hammer for
the armor Wars movie you just know oh
he's gotta be working with someone in
the shadows to get at Tony's Secrets
because if Iron Man 2 taught us anything
is that Justin Hammer isn't going to
steal Iron Man's Secrets himself but hey
there's also the slight possibility here
that Sonia fallsworth could be working
in tandem with the tan Rings
organization now headed up by Shang
Chi's sister mostly because of a few
factors one Sonia's brooch on her
clothes appears to be the shape of two
overlapping Reigns and two she is
literally surrounded by a bunch of
circular clocks both of which could be
Marvel's use of cinematography to tease
Sonia's connection to the 10 Rings
however the third and strongest link to
the 10 Rings we get in episode 1 is when
Sonia appears to already know of a heist
at a black market facility in Kazakhstan
when Nick Fury asked her about it what
do you know about a heist at a black
market storage facility in Kazakhstan
doesn't ring a bell you know I may not
know when a squirrel is pretending to be
a human but I sure as hell know when a
human is lying and the only entity in
the MCU that we've known so far to be
active in Kazakhstan are the ten rings
and in Iron Man 2 Pro comic that picks
up right after the first film ended
called Iron Man 2 public identity Iron
Man saves an air base in Kazakhstan
being overrun by the 10 Rings
organization so I think that there is a
strong chance here that Marvel Studios
could be picking up that narrative
thread of the 10 Rings influence in that
area of the world and then connecting it
to the secret Invasion narrative and
while Sonia could very well just be
aware of a heist in that country I have
a feeling that Sonya fallsworth might
just be a crooked MI6 agent looking to
set herself up for a cozy retirement as
a devious MCU spymaster the only time
will tell but anyways thank you guys so
much for watching this video you can
follow me at Master attainment on
Twitter if you guys want to see me tweet
some weird but most importantly
please support our growing Network by
buying a new secret Invasion or
spider-verse or any type of shirt over
at nerdrive.chop so thank you guys so
much for doing all that and for watching
and I'll see you guys later goodbye
foreign
[Music]